[Music]
thank you for your kind introduction
today i'm going to share with you
um the new 2021 cdc
hiv pre-exposure prophylaxis guidelines
and specifically emphasize on what these
new guidelines implications are for
clinicians and lab clinical laboratories
these are my conflict of interest
disclosures
uh relating to
some of the assays i'll be discussing in
this presentation
mainly
they relates to the molecular tests
that are currently
fda approved
for such use
and manufactured by roche molecular
diagnostics
in the next 40-45 minutes i will cover
the current hiv pre-exposure prophylaxis
landscape in the united states
describe important changes in the latest
2021
prep guidelines issued by the u.s
department of health and human services
and cdc
and finally
share with you
the new recommendations for laboratory
nucleic acid amplification tests
and the potential patient impact
now let's start with some definitions
prep is the abbreviation for hiv
pre-exposure prophylaxis and that is an
hiv prevention medication
initiated before
and continued throughout periods of
potential exposure to hiv
and i also want to make sure that the
audience
are familiar with the various terms that
we use for sex and gender identity
here's a table listing the four commonly
used term
in many of the publications as well as
patient education material relating to
prep
so we have four terms here cisgender men
uh they are individuals who are signed
as mailed at birth and identify
themselves as male
in their living daily living activities
and then we have transgender women or
tgw as an abbreviation
where they
were assigned as male at birth
but they identify themselves as female
and then we have cisgender women and
transgender men
so these are the terms that will be used
uh throughout the presentations
now let's take a look at the
us department of health human services
cdc initiative that was issued in 2019
and this was the initiative called
ending the hiv epidemic in the united
states
and the two of the major goals of this
initiative
were to use four science-based
strategies
namely diagnose
prevent
treat and respond
to reduce
the hiv
infection incidence by 90
by 2020 by 2030
and also
for those individuals who could benefit
from pre-exposure prophylaxis at least
50 percent of them
have been prescribed are using prep
so these are the two main goals
in this u.s federal government
initiative by 2030
and my presentation today will
concentrate on two of these
scientifically based strategies namely
diagnose hiv and to prevent hiv
now let's take a look at the current
status and progress of hiv prep united
states
of the 1.2 million individuals estimated
in the united states for whom prep is
currently recommended
those who actually were prescribed prep
actually has improved significantly
in the five years from 2015 to 2030. you
can see that back in 2015 of the
estimate of 1.2 million about three
percent actually were prescribed prep
whereas five years later in 2020 that's
the latest figure that the cdc has
they are now 25
but still a lot of room for
improvement
and this increase in prep from three to
25 percent over the five years have led
to an estimated decrease in new hiv
infection by eight percent now keep in
mind that these are preliminary cdc data
and um they are being verified for final
publications and this was issued in
april 2021
we are also uh be reminded that this
improvement in prep is actually very
uneven
the coverage
differs a lot across
racial and ethnic groups by age as well
as transgender
individuals
in the
2019-2020 u.s national hiv behavioral
surveillance study the data
uh
conducted and analyzed by the cdc
show that of the 92 percent of
transgender uh women
who are aware of prep only a third of
them
actually reported receiving prep
so that's actually only a third of
individuals who are eligible or should
be on prep are actually receiving prep
and preventing hiv infection
so these
inequalities actually
should be improved and strive for by all
levels of our health care system
and from this graph you can see that
in the report from 2020 in that one year
survey
the overall
coverage is 25 percent
but the
black and hispanic latino people
that account for majority
of
people for whom prep is recommended
they still have the lowest rate of prep
use among all racial and ethnic groups
the study
data show that only 9 and 16
of the nearly half a million black and
nearly 300 000 hispanic latino people
who could benefit from prep actually
receive a prep prescription in 2020.
a young individuals ages 16 to 24
uh are also less likely to be using prep
and only about 16
of these age group or whom prep is
recommended were actually prescribed to
in 2020 compared to
27 30
of those who are 25 to 34 and 34 to 44
respectively that are receiving prep in
that same year
so prep coverage
is uneven
um
among people based on gender
as well as age group
and
race and ethnicity
now let's take a look at the 2021
updated clinical practice guideline
issued by the u.s public health service
for prep
i'm going to just mainly highlight the
major updates
so one major update is that all sexually
active adults and adolescents should be
informed during their routine healthcare
visits as well as doing their visits for
sti
evaluation
that they should be informed about
availability of prep so these are not
just individuals who are at risk for hiv
acquisitions but all sexually active
adults and adolescents
carbotecrovir
which is a newly fda approved
medication antiretroviral
medication can be administered and
recommended now as an intramuscular
injection as a prep option so this is a
long active
integrase inhibitor drug that has been
shown in several clinical trials to be
effective in preventing hiv infection in
at risk individuals
the guideline also has revised the
previously recommended hiv testing
algorithm
to
two different algorithms depending on
the individual's
history of antiretroviral drug exposures
so one guideline is for those without
recent antiretroviral drug exposures
or use and a separate one for those
who are presenting for follow-up visits
while on prep or recent prep and the
recent prep definition will be shown in
the later slide
entry cytobean and tenofovir
elephantamide or abbreviated as f slash
taf is added as an fda approved prep
option for sexually active men and women
uh transgender women at risk of hiv
infections
now it's important here to note that
this drug combination is not fda
approved for prep
for those at risk through receptive
vaginal sex including cisgender women so
that's an important
note
of exceptions
and finally the frequency of accessing
estimated creatinine clearance
abbreviated as ecrcl
differs depending on the patient's age
or the
uh threatening clearance
at the time of
drug initiation
so for those who are younger or have
good renal function the monitoring for
creatinine clearance is needed only
every 12 months
for all others it's recommended that
they be monitored for
threatening clearance every six months
so let's take a look at the algorithm
recommended for assessing
individuals who are sexually active
for prep
so here we start out with
anal or vaginal sex in the past six
months
if they are not engaging in this
activity
then
discuss at least prep with them in case
if they do become sexually active
for those who do engage in sexual
activity
then
they are just
divided into these three separate groups
those who have a hiv
infected partner
known
or more than one partner
with unknown status and those were
actually who had a bacterial sexually
transmitted infection in the last six
months
so these individuals who engage in such
activity and has history of sti are at
increased risk of hiv infection so let's
start with those who had a known
hiv-infected partner
so if the partner
has a known
detectable
viral load
then they should actually be prescribed
um prep
those who do not have
uh known detectable viral load then at
least uh the individuals at risk should
be discussed
about uh prep and
be ready to receive prep
when indicated
those who do not have an hiv
infected partner then no prep is
indicated at this time
for those who have one or more
sexual partners of unknown hiv status
and they always use a condom in their
sexual activity
then prep is not indicated however prep
is if condom is not used
always then prep should be indicated
those who have unknown
sexual partners
do not have sexual partners with uh
known or unknown hiv status then
no testing no prep is indicated
now those who have a history of sti in
the last six months
uh if they belong to the s msm men who
have sex with men group have either
syphilis chlamydia or gonorrhea in the
last six months
they should be prescribed prep
those who actually are
men who have sex with men or women who
are heterosexually active individuals
then they should be prescribed prep as
well
now what about those who inject drugs
what are the indications for prep
so
those who did not of course
do not require
prep but if they do request prep then
prep should be prescribed because they
may not be forthcoming in sharing their
risk activities
now those who admitted to having
injection drug use and have used them in
the last six months
and do share injection equipment they
definitely should receive prep
those who did not have
injection drug use in the last six
months
then they do don't need to or if they
don't share
equipment injection equipment then prep
is indicated only upon requests
rather than recommended
there are also specific
recommendations for monitoring of these
individuals
doing prep
and the monitoring schedule and the
number of tests
recommended differs whether they are on
oral
prophylaxis versus long-acting
injectable
medications such as cabotegravir
so for those who are on oral prep it's
recommended that they get a baseline hiv
test which includes
nucleic acid testing so here one can
request a molecular test even if the
serologic test result is negative or
indeterminate because these individuals
who are requesting or being initiated on
prep maybe actually in the acute or very
recent hiv infection period where the
serologic tests are indeterminate or
negative
they should also have a baseline
creatinine clearance estimated along
with
testing for syphilis really serologic
tests for syphilis
and
sti screening for
genital
chlamydia
and also because the oral prep
medications have uh effects on
individuals lipid profile they should
have a baseline lipid panel
and also screen at the same time for
chronic or acute hepatitis b and acute
hep chronic hepatitis c
and they should receive
nat testing for hiv
at least every three months
and repeat sti screening every three
months
now
creatinine clearance is recommended for
those
who have borderline renal function or
greater than 60 years of age
every six months
and then also
for
individuals
who are stopping prep
all of these tests except for lipid
panel hepatitis and hepatitis c b and c
serology
um
these should be uh performed at the time
of stopping prep
for those who are on the long-acting
cabotager injections
very similar recommendations except that
lipid panel
creatinine clearance hepatitis b and c
serology are currently not recommended
or needed at baseline or during the
course of treatment
or prophylaxis sorry
and
they should however have nat testing
at one month after the visit
for initiation and then every two months
and
sti screening should occur
uh every four months
for these individuals
now how do we assess hiv infection
status either at baseline
or at follow-up visit so here
is the difference
to
the two testing algorithm that has been
implemented or recommended by the
guideline
so for those who never had or did not
have recent
anti-retroviral prophylaxis which is
defined as no oral prep
or post exposure prophylaxis in the last
three months
or have not received injectable
kabbategravir in the past 12 months
then they can start with
a serologic test
that measures and detect hiv antigen and
antibody
and the current standard
laboratory testing involves reflex
testing
uh depending on the initial screening
test results
and this can actually be a laboratory
based antigen antibody combination test
or a rapid test
such as a capillary or finger stick
blood with any one of the clear
approved
fda approved
test methods
if it's
non-reactive or indeterminate
they actually
should
go on
to be assessed for symptoms of signs of
acute hiv anytime in the last four weeks
or whether they have any known exposure
to a high risk behavior in the last four
weeks
if they have
and they're hiv negative
then they're not
hiv infected however if they report any
of these events with a indeterminate or
negative hiv serology test
they should proceed
to
molecular
there's
testing
option
to actually look for
hiv antibody
any antigen test again
that will test plasma rather than serum
if the original test was a whole blood
test that may not be as sensitive so
this the rationale for sending a plasma
for this test is that so that it's a
laboratory based test that has a much
better sensitivity compared to the
capillary or finger stick test done at
the point of care
now for those who undergo nat testing
then we look at whether the rna is
present and this can be performed by a
either quantitative or qualitative tests
so currently in the united states there
are actually two qualitative
tests that are fda approved for hiv-1
and hiv-2 rna
detection
the roche molecular kobas hiv-12
qualitative tests will detect hiv-1 and
hiv-2
rna separately
but reported on the same test results or
the hologic aptama hiv-1
qualitative tests that can detect hiv-1
rna qualitatively alone
so if they are
actually greater than
200 copies per ml in a qualitative test
they actually should be sent
for a new plasma collection
to
verify that this is indeed truly
positive because
uh 200 copies per ml is actually a
relatively low
viral count in somebody who's not
already on prep or any antiviral
medications
now those who are actually have no
symptoms
and
have no detectable or very low
detectable
hiv 1 rna they're considered hiv-1
negative
but for those who do have symptoms but
negative hiv won that then they should
be actually follow-up closely uh to
re-test in two to four weeks
after the initial net test results
now for those who actually have a
history
of recent or on currently on
antiretroviral prophylaxis use so that's
defined as an or any oral prep or post
exposure medication in the last three
months or have received carbotrovia
injection within the last 12 months they
should actually have a combination of
both
hiv antibody antigen combination screen
as well as nat testing at the same time
so not in a reflex setting
or algorithm like the previous algorithm
but simultaneously test for both
so it's important to communicate this
with
the clinical laboratories where these
specimens are being tested to be sure
that
the nat testing is actually part of the
initial evaluation or follow-up
evaluation
so here are the four possible outcomes
for these two tests if the serologic
test is reactive or positive
and the hiv-1 rna or hiv-2 rna is
positive then this individual is deemed
hiv-infected
however if both are negative then the
individual is considered not
hiv-infected
if the antibody antigen
result is positive with a negative hiv 1
2 net
then they actually should be sent a new
plasma specimen
for a qualitative and quantitative or
qualitative or quantitative hiv rna test
and
if
the result is reversed meaning negative
serologic tests but a positive nat test
and the same recommendation um is
indicated
and based on the
second plasma test
for qualitative
or quantitative rna tests if the rna is
positive individuals deem hiv infected
compared to those who are hiv
negative
now what's the rationale for
nat testing in these individuals who
have recent or ongoing
prep
to have nat testing the reason is
because
the
rise in hiv rna
is actually suppressed by these
long-acting
uh
anti-retroviral drugs like
carbo-tegravir
so you can see on the left-hand panel
under no
medication
we will see a spike in hiv rna prior to
development of hiv
or
anagen or antibody detection
and this spike in hiv rna is quite
prominent and usually in thousands or
millions of copies per ml
however under prep especially the
long-acting
antiviral
agent for prophylaxis like
carbo-tigravir
the
breakthrough infection
will occur
much later when the drug levels
are below suppressive
level or threshold
and you can see that the hiv rna also
will
be diminished in its rise and so
the dotted line represent the detection
level
of the respective tests
so hiv rna arise
during breakthrough infection while on
prep is much delayed and doesn't have
much of a rise compared to those who are
not on prep
at all
so nat testing is necessary to detect
these breakthrough infection during prep
earlier
than the antibody antigen
combination tests
so in summary
what we are seeing
in the recommendation is that depending
on the individual's
prep
history
the
monitoring
frequency uh differs
and the testing also differs
so for those who are on
prep in the last three months
or injectable cap cable technical in the
past 12 months
they should be sent
for
the laboratory base
antigen antibody combination screen and
either qualitative or quantitative hiv
nat test
and the frequency of monitoring
also depends on whether they're on oral
prep or injectable prep every three
months minimum for oral prep and every
two months
while on injectable prep and the higher
frequency of monitoring for injectable
prep
is because of
the
risk of emergence of resistance
in the long
acting uh anti-retroviral
uh cabotager
i wanted to
also talk about
new recommendations in the um cdc
clinical practice guideline about tele
health
uh we know that
uh in the last
two and a half years with the
covet 19 pandemic
a lot of things have actually prompted
healthcare providers to provide
telehealth
and also
encouraged by coverage from
center for medicare medicaid on their
medicare medicaid beneficiaries and
commercial insurance payers
and all these changes have enabled
enabled
expansion of telehealth visits to
replace some of the
increa in clinic visits that
led to
provision of prep
so one can now conduct prep screening
and initiation
as well as follow-up visit by phone or
web-based
consultations with clinicians
and
baseline as well as follow-up testing
for hiv sexually transmitted infections
and other prep related laboratory tests
such as threatening clearance monitoring
can now be done
with a simple specimen collection order
for the patient to present to the local
laboratories for blood tests and the
results set to the ordering provider
either electronically or by fax
or
special home specimen collection kits
now are available for requests
on these specific tests that have been
validated for such testing to be sent to
the patient's home for collection and
mail back to the performing laboratories
now only on very rare occasion and as a
last resort testing option for those who
have no possible
access to a laboratory or in person or
by mail
then the clinicians can
provide an oral swab-based self-test for
hiv so such as the oral quick
test using saliva
then the patients can conduct
the self-testing at home and report the
results to the clinician
preferably with a photo of the test
results shown
or sent to the ordering provider so this
is an option but only as a last resort
for those who have no
possible acts access
or be able to come
in person to the clinic
now once the hiv negative status is
confirmed then a prescription
can be provided for 90 days supply of
the prep medication rather than a 30-day
supply with two refills because this
30-day will minimize the trips that
individuals on prep needs to
present to the pharmacy and to also
facilitate prep adherence so adherence
is a major
important
component of successful
prep and prevention of
hiv infection
i also want to touch upon same-day prep
same-day prep is actually
a process by which individuals are
tested
with usually a point-of-care test
preferably either with a
antigen antibody combination
finger stick blood or other blood tests
and then
either oral or injectable
prep medication can be started on the
same day
and so if same day results can be
obtained from a laboratory test
then it's best to actually obtain a lab
blood specimen to be sent to the
performing lab for
a antigen antibody test
as well as a nat test
and important to note that the oral
fluid hiv tests should not be used
as
in same-day prep initiation and that the
reason is because
oral fluid hiv test does not have
adequate sensitivity to detect
acute hiv infection at the time of hi uh
prep initiation
blood should be drawn for creatinine
clearance estimation as well as hiv
testing
when same-day
testing or point-of-care tests and
creatinine tests are not available so
one can still draw blood
but without the results coming back
uh can still initiate prep
if it's indicated or desired by the
patient
when available a point-of-care
creatinine test should be done on
capillary blood so these are
commercially available
from the various medical institutions
and settings
it's important that the clinic providing
same-day prep
must provide assistance
to eligible patients to enroll in health
care
insurance medication co-payment
and medication assistance program
especially for those who are uninsured
or underinsured
and this is very important to facilitate
prep adherence
and also
one should be able to provide rapid
follow-up contact for patients when lab
test results indicate hiv infection or
renal dysfunction that requires changes
or stoppage of the prep medication
one should also provide scheduled
follow-up care appointments to these
individuals on same-day prep
and the facility prescribing same-day
prep should also have clinicians
available to prescribe and dispense oral
prep or administer intramuscular
injection of carbo-tegravir
and now for those who are not able to
uh
administer the injection
of carbo-tegavir but and the
individual's
desire long-acting injection then one
can actually prescribe a four-week
course of a lead-in oral carbotagravir
treatment i'm sorry prophylaxis
and this lead-in period
is usually
to
use in those individuals who are not
sure whether they can tolerate this
medication in the injectable form
and so a leading period of 30 days
or 28 days minimum
may be used for the first month of
carbotegravir prophylaxis
and if one is on this prophylaxis then
the first injectable dose
should be administered
on the last day of the oral lead-in
period or within three days after the
last injection of the last oral dose of
carbo-tegravir so this is an option
for those who are desiring
carbotegravir
prophylaxis
it's also important to recognize the
conjunctions to same-day prep and i have
listed them here
it's very important that those who do
not
have a confirmed means of contact
if the laboratory tests indicated a need
to stop prep such as hiv infection or
sudden deterioration of renal
dysfunction then these individuals
should not be prescribed same-day prep
so
that's just one of the major highlights
uh contraindications to same-day
preparations
now one last point i wanted to share
with you
is the risk of antiviral drug resistance
in individuals who are receiving and
potentially stopping or not being
adherent to prep
on the left hand side of this slide you
can see a graph
showing
the drug levels indicated in blue
when the last from the last dose of
prep
administered either oral or injectable
and this could be from either
um
the last injection of carbotagovir or
stopping uh carbotegravir
and the risk of emergence of resistance
is in indicated
with the shade color
as well as the dash red line
so with the declining drug
levels in the blood of the individuals
receiving
prophylaxis
the greatest risk is actually with
sub-optimal level of carbo-tigravir
not
doing when the carbo-trigger viewer or
the prep medication is at the lowest or
nil concentration
during the green
period
so when it's sub level
in the blood
the uh carbo the the virus actually has
the greatest potential
to emerge uh with resistance
uh with the noble
uh mutations
uh during this period
so it is important that
we educate
individuals about this tail effect
of declining carbotracheoviral levels in
the blood and the risk of emergence of
resistance
during this period
so these individuals
while on the last dose of prophylaxis
should be assessed
for ongoing risk
and prep indications
now if individuals cannot tolerate for
example the long-acting carbohydrate
injections or wish to switch to an oral
prep medication then that
oral combination
um should be started within eight weeks
after the last carbotagovir injections
and these combinations um are indicated
here the entry cytobean with
tenofovir alofenamide or turnoff of your
dysproxyl furamide
uh furamate
so one should also
educate about post post-exposure
prophylaxis because during this period
there's actually no effective
prophylaxis drug an individual
who are engaging in high-risk behavior
may actually been exposed during this
period these individuals should be
follow-up uh at least every three months
for a full year
and then also
they should have hiv nat testing uh
doing that every three months follow-up
after discontinuing couple tiger beer
and in summary
i wish to remind
you to discuss
sexual health with
sexually active adults and adolescents
and offer prep to them
especially if they requested them
important to assess hiv status carefully
prior to initiating pre-exposure
prophylaxis
and one needs to
assess and monitor hiv status
by laboratory testing differently
depending on the history of antiviral
exposure so those who have
received oral
or injectable
prophylaxis
versus those who have not seen
any antiviral
exposure
in the last 12 months for oral for
injectable
and for three months for oral
medications
there are now options available for
uh pre-exposure prophylaxis initiation
and follow-up by telehealth as well as
for same-day
prophylaxis initiation
and while individuals are on
prep
we should be aware of emergence of
antiviral resistance
and especially after discontinuing
injectable prep
before
either treatment or the subsequent prep
is initiated
thank you for your attention i'm happy
to
answer questions uh in the next 10 to 15
minutes thank you
you